Keg stands and paddle boards, forever associated
with inductions into well known exclusive
organizations, but they can get pretty brutal.
So why do people go through with it?
Hey guys Julia here for DNews.
Initiation rites seem as old as time.
Thousands of cultures participate in some
variation of them.
Here in America, we often associate them with
sports teams, social groups, Greek organizations
on college campuses, or the military.
Bullying is as old as we are too.
It’s when someone who is in a position of
power abuses someone beneath them.
Put them together and you get hazing.
Hazing is defined by Ramapo Journal of Law
and Society as “…any activity, required
implicitly or explicitly as a condition of
initiation or continued membership in an organization,
that may negatively impact the physical or
psychological well-being.”
Hazing…is like bullying but it’s a little
weird.
Here's a direct quote from a researcher, "It's
very rare for bullies to say, 'I'm going to
bully you for three months, but after that
we're going to be bros,' but that's the sort
of thing that happens with hazing."
Hazing isn’t fun, it’s not.
But that’s not what you might hear coming
out of the mouths of recent pledges.
And that’s because they’ve convinced themselves
they’re enjoying it.
I once had a friend in a frat, sorry he would
be mad if I said that, I should call it a
fraternity, who said he participated in hazing
because “shared PTSD makes you closer.”
What?
Well he’s not entirely wrong.
Sharing something brings people together,
whether it’s a meal, a victory, and yes,
even being hazed.
When you think of hazing you think of a few
things.
Drinking games and embarrassing dares, like
having intimate relations with a pig.
And turns out, it’s really effective in
making people want to join a group and in
making people really like the group their
joining.
Social psychology explains that hazing produces
cognitive dissonance - which is the mental
stress you feel when dealing with two contradictory
beliefs.
Early social psychology says that pledges
try to dispel that dissonance from hazing
in two ways.
“He can convince himself that the initiation
was not very unpleasant, or he can exaggerate
the positive characteristics of the group
and minimize its negative aspects”.
And the more unpleasant the initiation is,
the less they can convince himself of the
former, so they have to exaggerate the latter.
One famous 1959 psychology study found that
people liked the group they joined more if
they did something embarrassing to get in.
In this study researchers had college women
try to get into a book club.
Some women went through severe initiation,
some went through a mild initiation, and some
went through none at all.
But “severe” in this case was to read
obscene words out loud, and also read aloud
two vivid descriptions of sexual activity
from contemporary novels.
But hey it was the 50s, so that was DOWNRIGHT
SCANDALOUS.
Anyway, the researchers found that those who
went through the severe initiation rated the
group as significantly more attractive than
those women who went through other initiations.
Basically the harder it was to get into a
group the more they claimed they liked it.
And the harder the initiation, the greater
the dissonance, and the more they fight it…
by liking it.
So basically your brain is like “Wow this
sucks, why did I do this?
You know what, this club must be really cool
to get into”.
Hazing also forges these strong bonds between
pledges by wearing down their sense of individual
identity.
It can be physical OR psychological.
Because when people in a group are faced with
a threat, they rely more on the group and
look for group promoting behavior.
So basically you look around during something
traumatic and make sure everyone is in it
together.
This kind of shared trauma creates an intense
bond with other pledges and creates a distance
between themselves and non-group members.
Basically it creates a kind of us-vs-them
mentality among pledges and the veteran members.
And the experience of hazing itself, or ‘maltreatment’
at some researchers call it, makes pledges
feel dependent on the group, cognitively,
socially, and emotionally.
Because of what they went through together,
they now depend on the group for opinions
and validation.
You probably won’t be surprised to learn
there are some downsides to hazing.
One study published in the journal Group Dynamics:
Theory, Research, and Practice found that
undergrads who went through hazing had low
self esteem, rely on peers more, don’t like
to be left alone.
So while hazing and severe initiation might
be unpleasant and potentially dangerous, it
does exactly what it’s designed to do.
It wears identity down, strengthens bonds
with group members, convinces you that getting
abused is fun, and increases the prestige
of the team or group that you’re joining.
To get a little more background on how fraternities
and sororities became a common part of college
life, check out this video from Test Tube
News.
So have you ever been hazed?
Let us know down in the comments below